okay I told you earlier in the show
Donald Trump is off the rails after the
indictment of disgrace disgusting
depraved and delusional former National
Security Advisor Michael Flynn Trump in
a series of very strange tweets attacked
his own FBI saying that the reputation
of the FBI is in tatters and that's with
a capital T tatters is a proper noun in
the world of Trump and of course the
pattern I'm gonna show you and read to
you some of these tweets the pattern is
that they're all unintelligible and that
they mostly seem to be just a repetition
on a 30-minute delay of what's happening
on Fox News specifically and most
commonly what's happening on Fox and
Friends the first tweet from Donald
Trump about this Tainted no very
dishonest FBI agents role in Clinton
probe under review now there's just a
litany of parentheses and quotation
marks in these tweets and there's no way
that I can really translate that into
how I read it
so you'll have to see it to understand
it tainted no very dishonest FBI quote
agents rolling Clinton probe under
review end quote
lead Clinton email probe period email
capitalized I'm not sure why at Fox and
Friends Clinton money going to wife of
another FBI agent in charge okay Trump
staying on Twitter over the weekend
after years of Comey with the phony and
dishonest Clinton investigation and more
comma running the FBI its reputation is
in tatters tatters capitalized
worst in history history also
capitalized but fear not we will bring
it back to greatness and this is an
attack on on his own FBI right I mean
you the guy running the FBI now chris
ray that's his name right pat that's
someone Trump picked to run the FBI are
you telling us Donnie that the lowest
point in history of the FBI is when the
guy you picked is running it not exactly
a ringing endorsement of his own ability
to appoint people and then another tweet
from Donald Trump report all caps and
quoted and
hi Trump FBI agent lead Clinton email
probe now it all starts to make sense
and what is fascinating is that Fox and
Friends had that exact quote up on
screen at 8:07 a.m. Eastern Time right
report anti-trump FBI agent led email
probe that's on Fox and Friends at 8:07
29 minutes later at 836 a.m. Trump
tweets it Trump's basically following
Fox & Friends the Trump mindset is
directly controlled by Fox & Friends
if you are Fox & Friends do you realize
the amount of power that you wield right
now because the president seems to
mostly be following your reports yeah it
could be the most powerful TV show in
the whole country I would say in some
incredibly bizarre way I think it is and
then this morning Trump also continuing
to tweet about Fox & Friends a must
watch legal scholar scholar capitalized
as well Alan Dershowitz was just on Fox
and Friends talking of what is going on
with respect to the greatest witch hunt
witch hunt capitalized in US political
history enjoy it is the Fox and Friends
presidency and if we look back at the
last six to nine months if Trump is out
there proactively trying to discredit
the his own FBI in this way my question
is what's the FBI about to release
because the growing hysteria from Trump
about the FBI to me signals the FBI is
getting close to something big because
the timing of it when Trump starts
attacking some institution it's
sometimes right after but sometimes is
right before there's some kind of major
release a revelation yeah and I really
think that Trump could be the most anti
law-enforcement president we've ever
seen and whether it's going after his
own Attorney General Jeff Sessions or
undermining the intelligence agencies
when they agree that yes Russia did try
to infiltrate the election indeed now at
the FBI and the probe into him it's
craziness but when Republicans do it
it's okay it's when the left does it
that they don't respect our institutions
the pillars that our democracy is built
on and it's also all projection right
the FBI's reputation isn't really in
tatters but Trump as president as the
president of the United States has led
to the
mutation of the us being in actual
tatters around the world it's all
projection and the real tragedy as is
often the case is that the President of
the United States is publicly
denigrating institutions of the United
States federal institutions in other
cases cultural and social institutions
and his followers instead of saying no
it has to stop here they say oh yeah we
agree Trump is the only guy who's
willing to tell these truths the video
you just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad